welcome to the man of Recaps this is
Andor season one meet Cassian Andor who
would go on to become a hero of the
rebellion in Star Wars Rogue one but for
now he's living a quiet life on ferricks
the junkyard Planet he's basically a
grifter who steals valuable parts from
Salvage ships while his friends with
jobs look the other way and he's the
classic kind of charming Rogue who is
friends with but owes money to everyone
in town but tonight he visits a bar
because he heard a girl from qunari
works there kunari was his home planet
he's hoping it is his long-lost sister
when they were kids a ship crashed there
and things went bad Cassian ended up
Bound by this ferric scavenger Marva she
became his loving adopted mother and has
a cute old Droid B2 anyway his sister
search it's a dead end but some
corporate security guards are ready to
pick a fight they try to shake him down
outside but Cassian Fights Back
unfortunately he fought back too hard
and killed one of them and he can't
leave Witnesses has to kill the other so
in the morning he visits his
ex-girlfriend Bix who has a contact
that's a wealthy buyer he's gonna sell
this one piece he's been holding on to
for enough money to get out of town so
she calls her mystery buyer on their
secret radio and it is none other than
Stellan Skarsgard a character named
Lutheran so katha's gonna sell him this
Imperial starpath unit he has it's like
well man how'd you get that but
cassian's like look I'm good at what I
do I just walked on to an imperial ship
wearing a maintenance outfit and took it
and Lutheran's like hey I'm not just
here to buy this I'm recruiting for the
rebellion and we want you but meanwhile
corporate security is looking into these
murders the chief is like hey it was
clearly a bar fight gone wrong we're not
going to investigate but a second in
command Cyril is a real uptight guy who
takes his job seriously and is like hey
this is now Priority One so security
teams come in for cast their meetings
cut shorty and Luther have to work
together to escape their escape car gets
blown up but it was a distraction Escape
car all Lutheran's the man boom
meanwhile on Coruscant yes the Star Wars
Capital Planet our main antagonist is
diedram hero an up-and-coming agent at
the ISB the Imperial Security Bureau
Cassian stolen starpath unit is just one
of a lot of missing Tech that she thinks
is part of an organized Rebel conspiracy
but she's having a hard time getting her
bosses to listen meanwhile Cyril is very
much fired he goes home to live with his
mom and falls into a Serial depression
his mom's like don't worry I'll call
Uncle Harlow who gets him a job at the
most boring Department in the Empire now
Luther's like hey man you hate the
Empire you should join the Rebellion but
cassian's like no that's too dangerous I
gotta look out for myself all right well
what if you do just one Mission because
I'm putting together a heist and we'll
pay you cassian's like well I could do
that so they fly down to Shepherd planet
where Vel is running the heist team then
Cassie and befriends the whole Motley
Crew but Lutheran himself is not
sticking around he's got to go back to
his cover identity where he's a
flamboyant high-end artifact dealer so
yeah he's basically Batman where his
real identity of Bruce Wayne is just a
cover for his true self where he's a
secret Rebel badass who drives a really
sweet souped-up car and we get to see
he's the true architect of the Rebellion
pulling strings behind the scenes and
trying to unify all the different
factions like saw Guerrera who we meet
later in Rogue one into one unified
Rebellion his biggest Ally on Coruscant
is mon mothma who we know later becomes
the head of the Rebellion right now
she's that token Senator who's trying to
make the Empire less evil and everyone
mostly ignores her but behind the scenes
she's working with luffin giving him
money to fund the Rebellion now back to
the heist turns out this remote Garrison
has a ton of money in it and our crews
got a man on the inside and to cover
their escape they're gonna go on the
night of on Epic meteor shower so as the
locals come for their meteor shower
party our crews posing as guards and
while everyone's focused outside our
crew infiltrates and starts loading up a
buttload of cash it goes smoothly until
the very end but now what's this oh it's
beautiful and an epic cover for their
escape some Tie fighters chase after him
but Cassie and endorse and Ace pilot
flies up above it till they can't follow
and are gang's home free but tragically
this young guy died and he was a True
Believer who wrote The Rebel Manifesto
and now this other guy turns on him
forget the Rebellion you and me and or
will split that cash what kind of person
is Cassian not that kind he shoots this
guy but he does bail on Bell like hey I
was just paid for this one job I'm going
to take my cut and bounce but overall
The Heist was a huge success massive
blow to the Empire and the Rebellion is
funded but The Empire Strikes Back they
start cracking down hard everywhere
agent mirrors now free to investigate
the star path unit which leads her to
interview our boy Cyril he's like this
is my chance please give me a job but
she's like no man you're a loser he
doesn't take no for an answer though and
kind of starts stalking her he's like
look I've Got a Boner for the Empire and
also for you personally and this becomes
the awkward uptight villain romance I
didn't expect to be rooting for anyway
she doesn't know Lutheran's identity but
she suspects there's someone behind the
scenes pulling the strings she calls him
axis and Cassian Andor is the only one
who can identify him so he's now the
Empire's Most Wanted and Lutheran can't
risk exposure he liked Andor but has to
find him first and kill him he has his
loyal assistant Clea talked to Belle and
put her on the job and incidentally
Vettel is mon mothma's cousin yeah she's
got a Batman double life too so everyone
in the galaxy is looking for Andor the
Empire cracks down hard on ferricks and
tortures Bix with the screams of dying
children but Cassian himself has no
worries he's retired to South Beach
Planet until some guys do a crime nearby
and through bad luck cassian's picked up
for it and with the Empire's new
Crackdown there's no trials Cassian
sentenced to six years in prison and so
it's an absurdly ironic situation where
the Empire's Most Wanted they've already
caught him unbeknownst to them for a
crime he didn't even commit now this
prison has a unique defense system
because the floor is electrified so
there's no chance of misbehavior his
floor manager his fellow inmate Kino Loy
and a surprise Cameo from Andy Circus
it's a forced labor prison where they're
making Death Star parts and the whole
all things gamified in a bleakly
dystopian way they're all competing
against each other daily winners get to
eat much with flavor and daily losers
are electrified so a month goes by as
Cassian settles into his new living hell
but there's a shake-up when they learn
someone just released was sent right
back in their sentences are a lie no
one's getting out so the next day it's
Prison Break Time Of course electrified
floors could shut that right down but
this whole time cassian's been cutting
the water pipe so now he breaks it and
they Electrify the floor all the water
shorts it out they make it to the
control room where Andy Circus gives an
epic monologue there's only one way out
I know yes it's a full-on prison break
so sweet but that one way out involves
swimming and in a tragic twist of fate
Kino can't swim but ISB doesn't care
about this they're excited because they
just learned one Rebel faction is going
to attack a place so this one agent goes
for a secret meeting with Lutheran yeah
he's the man on the inside but it's like
look I can't warn them because the
Empire will know they have a mole and
this guy's like what you're just willing
to sacrifice them like what do you
sacrifice and Lutheran gives the epicus
monologue I burn my life for a sunrise I
will never see he basically says he's
embraced the darkness to fight the
darkness uh really hammering home the
Batman thing mon mothma also sacrificing
for the Rebellion she's been funding it
but now the Empire is cracking down on
money transfers they're gonna find her
her only option is to work with the
crime Lord on our home planet and he's
at the point in his career he doesn't
want money he wants the social club to
befriending a senator and so in the
tradition of their Planet they engage
their teenage kids then in the car she
picks a huge fight with her husband
about his gambling problem he's like
what what gambling problem but she knows
her driver is an ISB agent and that'll
cover where the money's going so
sacrificing her family for the Rebellion
meanwhile Cassian has made it to Freedom
with his one fellow inmate who's in row
one later but now he gets some bad news
from back home his mother Marna has died
and so everyone heads back to ferrics
hoping Cassian will come home for the
funeral and so it's an epic funeral
marching band finale I never thought I'd
say epic and marching band in the same
sentence before she died his mom made a
recording where now she gives an epic
monologue about fighting the Empire and
gives Luther a run for his money and
when the Empire tries to shut it down
now they incite the full-blown Riot and
the chaos Miro ends up in trouble but
her stalker followed her here and rushes
in to save her and it's just hilarious
how much I'm rooting for this evil
romance but in this Grand Finale Cassian
Andor is nowhere to be seen because he's
using it as cover to rescue Bix he gets
her to an escape ship with all their
best friends but cassian's not going
with him he's needed elsewhere because
earlier he saw that Lutheran was here so
he goes to his ship and gets the drop on
him but it's like hey man no need to
kill me because I'm now in for the
Rebellion 100 yes Cassian Andor is ready
to fight and that is where and or season
one comes to an end
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]